It’s said that symmetry is fundamentally beautiful.
But how fundamental is that?
Hey Crazies.
My life is usually pretty hectic in March, but it’s Women’s History Month,
so I wanted to take some time to honor a very important woman in physics:
Emmy Noether
Wasn’t she a mathematician?
Technically, yes, but physics got to borrow her brilliance for a few days.
This story takes place in Guttingen, Germany in 1915
Einstein and Hilbert were trying to finish general relativity,
but they ran into a little snag.
If energy warps space-time and space-time contains energy,
then space-time should be able to warp space-time.
That’s what we call a paradox!
They needed a fresh set of eyes, so they invited Noether to the university.
By that time, she was already known for being a brilliant mathematician.
I mean, here’s a list of her accomplishments.
But the invitation was met with such heavy resistance from the establishment
that Hilbert had to advertise her lectures
under his name
and list her as an “Assistant.”
Totally ridiculous!
It’s a good thing they found a loophole though because,
without Emmy Noether, general relativity may never have been finished.
Right, relativity, we were talking about a paradox.
It turns out not all energy warps space-time.
Just the stuff in this stress-energy tensor,
which is all the energy except the energy in space-time itself.
Space-time is on one side, everything else
is on the other.
This was a good enough explanation for a physicist, but Noether was a mathematician
and like a true mathematician:
She generalized it to death!
Total energy is what we call a conserved quantity,
which is a quantity that does not change.
As a result of her work on general relativity,
Noether notably noticed something.
I’m such a dork.
She noticed where all conserved quantities actually come from.
Symmetry!
Now, just to keep things clear, we’re not talking about the visual symmetry,
you see in things like organisms and playing cards.
We’re talking about mathematical symmetry!
To demonstrate this, I’ve made some expendable clones.
Hi! Wait, expendable?
Well, we can’t exactly do this in the space station.
Don’t be ridiculous. Too many distractions.
Here’s a clone just floating in space.
It’ll still be floating over here, or over here, or over here.
If the clone is moving in a straight line, it’ll do that here,
or here, or here.
That’s what we call translational symmetry and, in all of those situations,
the clone’s linear momentum is conserved.
The symmetry implies that linear momentum cannot change.
It’s even true if we have more than one clone in the system.
What’s happening doesn’t change if they’re here,
or here, or here.
Yes, we do lose the symmetry if we put them
over here,
but then we also lose the momentum conservation.
Unless, of course, we expand our system to
include the Earth.
Rotational symmetry implies angular momentum can’t change.
If the system of clones is here, but oriented
like this instead,
then their physics doesn’t change,
which is true if they’re like this
or like this or like this!
Time symmetry implies energy can’t change, but that’s a little harder to show with clones.
The idea is that you don’t have to set zero time at the Big Bang.
You can start your clock whenever you want.
Which is why we can have things like time zones
and we can switch our clocks to daylight savings time.
Although, no one ever should, don’t get
me started.
The main point here is that Emmy Noether was brilliant
and her theorem was incredibly insightful.
You might even say that it was beautiful.
And until next time, remember, it’s OK to
be a little crazy.